salut l'emmental au aujourd'hui on va
parler des micro expressions du visage
j'en profite également pour souhaiter la
bienvenue à tous les nouveaux qui
viennent d'arriver sur la chaîne j'ai un
message à la fin de la vidéo pour tous
les abonnés donc ce sera la fin de la
vidéo après là haute trop dans notre
visage on à 94 muscles différents et
dans notre coût 85 muscles différents
c'est beaucoup en général on utilise
environ 10000 expressions du visage
différentes mais on les voit très peu on
utilise donc des expressions on les
contrôle ou pas mais en général on les
contrôle on maîtrise un petit peu ce
qu'on fait et les micro-expressions elle
dure très peu de temps un 25e 2 secondes
jusqu'à une demi-seconde grand maximum
et c'est bien le but de ce master class
port la 246e vidéo de l'année je me suis
dit qu'on allait parler des
micro-expressions un contrôle et celles
qui passent très furtivement celle qu'on
maîtrise pas consciemment et qui donne
donc des indications non verbale sur ce
qu'on ressent tout l'enjeu est là c'est
lié à des émotions c'est lié à des
sentiments c'est lié à ce qu'on ressent
intérieurement c'est à dire que si on se
force à faire travailler les muscles
d'une micro expressions particulières
alors ça va faire des changements
internes dans le corps et dans l'état
d'esprit ça va changer notre émotion
essayer de faire ça en même temps que
moi vous détendez le bas du visage vous
lever les sourcils vous écarquillés au
maximum les yeux et vous essayer de
rapprocher comme ça vos sourcils et un
de l'autre comme ça le plus possible de
les rapprocher de plus en plus de plus
en plus de plus en plus de plus en plus
et là ça provoque un ce léger sentiment
de peur vous retrouver cette sensation
d'angoissé
alors elle est légère évidemment vous
avez pas avoir peur en regardant la
vidéo mais ça vous permet de comprendre
le rapport entre les micro-expressions
et les émotions une micro expressions
c'est vrai c'est pas truqué on peut
truquer un sentiment de joie on peut
truquer un sentiment de peur on peut
faire semblant sur son visage c'est
aussi ce que font les comédiens
d'ailleurs mais à l'expression réelle
des sentiments fait travailler certains
muscles qu'on ne contrôle pas
habituellement et ça on peut pas tricher
on voit tout de suite quels sont les
vrais expression contrairement aux idées
reçues ce n'est pas paul ekman qui a
découvert les micro-expressions comme
tout le monde le dit monde le croit
depuis la série lie to me même s'il a
fait beaucoup pour le sujet le premier à
s'intéresser à ça au niveau des humains
et des animaux c'est darwin qui a publié
en 1872 un livre là-dessus
l'expression des émotions chez l'homme
et les animaux mais c'est seulement en
1966 qu à garer isaac ont inventé
employés du moins le terme micro
expressions c'est les premiers à avoir
fait ça ils ont utilisé ce terme là
après avoir visionné des films de
psychanalystes avec le patient et le
psychanalyste qui étaient en face ils
ont regardé ça avec des ralentis ils ont
étudié ce à ce moment là ils ont dit
ça c'est une micro expressions monsieur
et c'est seulement au début des années
90 que paul ekman a apporté sa pierre à
l'édifice avec d'énormes travaux là
dessus il ad'ailleurs détecter des
nouvelles émotions par rapport à celle
qui existait déjà mais ça je vous en
reparlera après et c'est lui qui a
inspiré la série lie to me que vous
connaissez il a été consultant pour
cette série coacher les comédiens ce qui
fait que c'était assez précis en fait
tout ce qu'on voit dans cette série
plutôt précis est réelle quand je dis
tout c'est pas tout non plus je vous
vois venir dans les commentaires mais
c'est quand même un support précis qui
n'existait pas jusqu'à aujourd'hui même
si c'est fait sous forme de fiction
aujourd'hui on dit par convention qui
lie à cette micro expressions
différentes que vous pouvez détecté en
parlant avec quelqu'un c'est à dire ou
discuter avec quelqu'un et elle passe
très rapidement
souvenez vous un 25e de seconde 1 16ème
de secondes si vous arrivez à la
détecter vous savez ce que pensent
réellement la personne au moment où elle
vous parle la première c'est la joie la
vraie joie la joie sincère avec le vrai
sourire ou les joues se tendent
réellement vers le haut ou c'est pas
juste les pommettes qu'on aide à
remonter
il ya comme des petites rides qui
apparaissent autour des yeux ce qu'on
appelle les pattes d'oie la bouche qui
s'ouvre pour commencer à sourire des
fois même pour faire un sourire c'est
d'ailleurs ça qu'on appelle le sourire
authentique le sourire authentique c'est
un sourire qu'on peut pas réfréné on
peut pas le garder on peut pas le
retenir et à ce moment là le muscle
orbiculaire souris en même temps que la
bouche c'est ça qu'on appelle les yeux
rieurs en deuxième micro expressions
universel puisque je crois que je
voulais pas précisé mais elle sont
universelles c'est-à-dire ce soit l'une
tribus dans le fin fond du monde cas pas
de contact avec les autres ou une
civilisation européenne ou asiatique
on a tous la même manière d'exprimer ses
émotions là c'est pour ça que c'est
l'une des clés les plus importantes du
non verbal
je disais donc en deuxième la surprise
avec les yeux qui s'écarquillent la
bouche qui s'ouvrent et les sourcils qui
remonte mais les sourcils en entier
c'est à dire les intérieurs et les
extérieurs en troisième la colère avec
la mâchoire crispée l'élève qui se
resserre les sourcils qui froncent c'est
à dire que les deux pointes intérieur
commence à s'abaisser en 4e le dégoût
avec cette partie là qui commencent à
remonter légèrement
ces deux canaux là au niveau du nez
parfois un début de crispation est
toujours la lèvre supérieure qui remonte
pas tout la bouche juste la lèvre
supérieure
un exemple concret de dégoût comme ça
spontanée sincère je crois que c'est
clair
en cinquième le mépris qui une micro
expressions très intéressante puisque
c'est la seule qui est asymétrique
il n'y a qu'une seule partie du visage
qui va rentrer en mouvement et alain
côté un petit peu et logique c'est à
dire que plus
des mouvements musculaires vont être
faible plus le mépris va être fort parce
qu'il ya une tentative de dissimuler et
ça c'est un signe que le mépris encore
plus fort avec plein de représentation
différente
quelque chose qui est toujours commun au
mépris c'est une partie des lèvres qui
commence à se contracter comme sur cette
photo cette photo de personnes prises
complètement au hasard
évidemment pour l'anecdote cette micro
expressions elle est passée sur son
visage lors du débat en 2007 qu'il avait
face à ségolène royal pour les
présidentielles où il y avait des et
alors les 35 heures vous en faites quoi
la sixième avec des yeux qui
s'écarquillent avec les sourcils qui
remonte sauf la partie intérieure qui
s'abaisse avec la lèvre qui s'en trouve
la peur j'ai une image très
intéressantes concernant la peur c'est
avec miss caroline du sud où là on voit
bien qu'elle a un sourire de façade qui
est kimi pour les joueurs et pour le
public pour les gens qui la regardent à
la télévision
mais si on oublie ce sourire qui est
faux et qu'on regarde les yeux les yeux
sont écarquillés des sources il remonte
il s'abaisse tous les muscles de la peur
sont en marche en fait allé en stress et
elle a vraiment peur de ce moment et
enfin la 7e micro-expressions
universelle c'est celle de la tristesse
avec tout le visage qui se détend qui
s'abaisse et la bouche qui forment une
espèce de u1 versés pour ceux qui
aimeraient aller plus loin dans les
descriptifs musculaire complet de tout
ça je vous mets un lien dans le
descriptif avec mal lui en a rajouté une
dizaine assez universel là alors il ya
un petit débat est-ce qu'on se sont
vraiment universel ou pas parce que
d'une culture à une autre il ya des
choses qu'on appelle les sentiments qui
s'apprennent au contact en fait des gens
qui nous entourent et de la société donc
on va avoir une manière d'exprimer telle
ou telle chose parce qu'on est né à tel
ou tel endroit et que c'est plutôt ça
qu'on fait là-bas
néanmoins en universelle ou quasi
universelle et puis si elles sont pas
universelles elles sont quand même
intéressante pour les pays occidentaux
ce sont les micro-expressions de
l'intérêt d'excitation de la culpabilité
de la honte de l'orgueil du soulagement
de la satisfaction et du plaisir on les
appelle les émotions secondes
alors c'est sûr c'est pas facile de
détecter ça il faut être très attentif
dans une conversation c'est même plus
facile après à regarder sur un film mais
vous pouvez essayer de le faire ou de
vous entraîner à le faire on peut déjà
s'améliorer à détecter ça puisque si on
n'y prête attention forcément on est
beaucoup plus présent la discussion et
on les voit mieux passé mais il ya des
personnes qui sont plus sensibles que
d'autres à sas et même des petits génies
des micro-expressions qui servent les
détecter à dix mille kilomètres
j'exagère un peu sur les dix mille
kilomètres en tout cas qui n'en rate pas
une et que mal à même créé un programme
qui s'appelle génique un espèce de
programmes de super détecteur de ces
gens là
ils ont fait passer vingt mille
personnes sur ce programme et sur les
20000 il y avait cinquante personnes qui
naturellement savait dès détecter les
interpréter c'était assez inconscient en
fait un espèce de dons peut-être que
vous aussi vous arrivez à détecter des
choses sur sur des gens où vous avez des
anecdotes à ce sujet en ayant vu une
micro expressions passées où on ayant
détecté quelque chose d'un peu non
verbal pour interpréter une discussion
mettez le mois dans les commentaires je
serai ravi de lire ça et vos anecdotes
avoue petite précision quand même pour
ceux qui vont essayer de le faire un peu
comme sur la vidéo que j'avais fait sur
le col trading que je vais vous mettre
là par là où je sais pas trop où ça
parait il est important d'avoir une base
line d avoir plusieurs tel pour valider
quelque chose c'est à dire c'est pas
parce que vous détectez une micro
expressions particulières qu'elle
correspond à l'interprétation direct que
vous en avez imaginez vous parler avec
quelqu'un une personne proche à vous
deux qui est décédé il ya longtemps où
il ya pas longtemps et vous voyez micro
expressions de joie passer sur son
visage
donc en interprétation directe on
pourrait dire qu'il n'aimait pas cette
personne alors que ça peut être au
contraire qui va se souvenir qu'il
revient un souvenir nostalgique et qu'il
est joyeux de ce souvenir là n'oubliez
jamais que dans le non verbal
une chose ne suffit pas une validation
complète merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé
ce master class sur les
micro-expressions c'était le premier si
vous voulez que j'en fasse un autre vous
me le dites aussi dans les commentaires
il n'y a pas de souci on pourra aller un
petit peu plus loin de toute manière je
voulais dit dans le descriptif vous
retrouverez quand même des liens pour
aller un petit peu plus loin que ça
si cette vidéo vous a plu en tout cas
merci de me le faire savoir en laissant
un pouce en l'air et peut-être gagner
tous ses pouces en l'air moment donné je
regardais la la vidéo et moi aussi
j'aurai une expression de joie à les
étranges ma joie c'est une joie
personnelle c'est une micro explosion
personnel pensez à vous abonner avant de
partir puisque je vous rappelle que le
mental blog c'est une vidéo par jour
depuis le 1er janvier jusqu'au 31
décembre
donc rendez vous demain à 11 heures
parce que le week-end ses 11 heures ciao